أشعر بالأمان
لأنك لم تعد في خطر لأن هذا مطلق
النار رحل نواب شريف يقولون إن
المسلح المشتبه به الذي فتح النار على
استوديو للرقص في مونتيري بارك بكاليفورنيا
ليلة السبت مات إنه ذكر آسيوي يبلغ من العمر 72 عامًا
يمكنني أن أؤكد أنه لا يوجد شيء
معلق  المشتبه بهم يقول الشريف إن
المشتبه به أطلق النار على نفسه في شاحنته
خلال مواجهة بعد ساعات من
مقتل 10 أشخاص وإصابة
10 آخرين في جنوب كاليفورنيا.  في
احتفالها بالعام القمري الجديد ، نحن نبحث في كل
التاريخ الإجرامي لتاريخ الصحة العقلية
كما في معرفة ما إذا كانت هناك أي ثغرات ربما تكون قد
فاتتنا
ثلاثة أشخاص عرفوه أخبر سي إن إن أنه
اعتاد أن يكون منتظمًا في قاعة
رقص النجوم.  الاستوديو وحتى التقى
بزوجته السابقة هناك بعد وقت قصير من الهجوم
في مونتيري بارك ، تقول السلطات إن
نفس المشتبه به ذهب إلى استوديو ثانٍ في
قصر الحمراء القريب ، لكن الناس هناك
تمكنوا من نزع سلاحه قبل أن يفر ،
وبينما تواصل السلطات
تحقيقها.
يُترك المجتمع للتعامل مع العنف الذي لا معنى له ،
إنه عادةً ما يشبه إلى حد كبير
التوجه الأسري ، لكننا شعرنا
بالصدمة لسماع أنك تعلم أنه
يحدث هنا
ولا يمكن أن يكون في أي مكان